I said about a month ago that we have to keep
focusing on what's happening in the courts
and I'm going to do that today.
Yesterday, Donald Trump was impeached.
That was important.
That was the correct outcome based on the
facts.
Again, Republicans in the Senate pushed through
11 more judges in the Senate.
If we think about the future of this country,
there are many important things.
Immigration policy, healthcare policy, who
is the president of the United States who
is on the Supreme court but much more quietly.
Republicans are being smart and they are setting
themselves up for a massive rightward move
in the judiciary for decades with the judges
that they are pushing through with very few
comparatively, people noticing that they're
doing it.
Mitch McConnell has successfully pushed through
a record, 50 appellate court judges.
Remember, most cases never make the Supreme
court.
They're decided at lower levels.
That's why this is so important.
Plus, of course, we know about Donald Trump's
two Supreme court picks Neil Gorsuch and Brett
Kavanaugh, one of which should have been Obama's
pick of Merrick Garland.
Remember every two hours yesterday, the Senate
was voting on a judge and pushing through
these Trump nominees.
They have been sickeningly efficient and it
doesn't get the media attention that it deserves,
but I've been making the effort to talk about
it and I'm going to continue 11 nominees in
August of 20 1815 nominees in October of 2018
and on and on and on through Donald Trump's
presidency.
Now, as I've told you before, at different
court levels, many of Donald Trump's picks
have been rated not qualified by the American
bar association.
These are people who have no business being
judges.
They are blindly partisan political actors
who don't even qualify on the basis of the
American bar association.
And some of these are lifetime appointments
and these people will get to make law via
their decisions for a very, very long time.
And in fact, Mitch McConnell isn't stupid
and he at least must be thinking a 2020 blood
bath is possible for Republicans.
They could lose the house, uh, they, they
could have an even bigger deficit in terms
of the house split a balance of power.
They could lose the white house, they could
lose the Senate, although they are likely
to keep it.
They might not though there is no better insurance
policy politically than packing any court
that you can with as many of your people as
possible, particularly blindly partisan actors.
And that is exactly what they are doing.
Mitch McConnell is a bad faith actor.
He's truly a scourge and the American political
system, and he has been for a long time, but
this guy knows how to operate.
I've said this before, I hate the guy in terms
of his politics, but the obstruction he pulled
off during the Obama administration headline
course by denying Barack Obama a Supreme court
seat that should have been his, should have
been Merrick Garland's seat, uh, that was
put on hold, held it so that Donald Trump
ultimately got to choose a replacement stuffing
the courts at all levels with their judges.
It could take a generation to rebalance courts
from what Mitch Mitch McConnell did.
So love him or hate him and I'm disgusted
with him.
It's undeniable that he has quietly been one
of the most effective Senate majority leaders
in modern American politics.
And quite frankly, this is one reason that
Republicans keep tolerating Trump.
It's not all about this, but under the cover
of public Trump scandal and impeachment and
all of this other embarrassment internationally
that Donald Trump engages in getting dozens
and dozens of judges through into a lot of
lifetime positions is an unconscionable political
win.
The tax windfalls for some people who support
Trump certainly didn't help, but this is Republicans
winning for 30 to 40 years with the influence
that some of these judges are going to have.
This is a red alert setback for the country.
Unqualified activist judges who have no idea
what's going on.
We'll butcher and we'll mold the law like
putty to fit their right wing worldview often
informed by religion, sometimes just informed
by reactionary politics.
This is an argument for many things.
It's an argument for term limits for judges.
Yes, it's also an argument for we need to
be able to focus on more than one thing at
a time and we need to force corporate media
to do so as well and really, really important,
and I say this because we're heading, we are
almost in an election year.
Once again, we need to immediately throw in
the trash talking points like those that were
parroted by some on the left in 2016 like
if it's not X, I don't care between Hillary
and Trump, it's sort of all the same.
Just on the issue of judges alone, you could
not be more wrong.
Forget about any other aspect of it.
We really need to get back to the drawing
board on that because the right is crushing
us on this issue.
Much like they've been crushing us at the
local level in many ways, much like they'd
been crushing us on properly funding a young
activists coming out of college to become
conservative leaders of the, the left doesn't
do this even though, you know, we do have
money.
Conceivably, money is out there, but it's
not used in this particular way.
They're crushing us in a lot of places and
we're only doubling down on the, uh, damage
that they do.
When we say stuff like Hillary Trump, sort
of all the same, the judges confirm it is
not bigly.
Bigly confirmed that